Ashwin is with us in Texas hi Ashman how
are you hi Dave Ramsey and Chris how you
doing great how can we help
hi so I'm recently divorced I have four
small children and I was awarded the my
house and my car in the divorce
well my mortgage went up from twelve
hundred fifty two dollars to fifteen
forty because they came and reappraise
the house and so I'm kind of I can
afford it but I kind of don't want to
afford it so I'm thinking about selling
it the only dilemma is is that I have a
broken leaves on my credit credit report
I just tried to call them and settle
with them but they did not want to take
my settlement and so I'm just trying to
see should I just stay in the house or I
don't really know what to do
got you so tell me this right now how
much do you think the home is worth I
could probably sell the house for about
a hundred seventy thousand and I owe 140
okay and you're just guests ballparking
on that correct well okay and then how
much do you owe on the car Oh about
eighty eight hundred dollars okay and
how much is that payment you're making
each month six hundred seventy three
dollars
oh my goodness that's big and so what's
your household income right now without
any kind of alimony or child support
just your income right now about twenty
thousand dollars is that a year okay and
then are you getting alimony and child
support as well
whoa okay all right so no matter how
much alimony and child support you get I
get 1,700 a month
okay so what makes you think you can
afford to keep this house because I've
been affording it oh yeah
no you haven't oh yeah you just got
divorced your 10th your Tet this is over
50% of your take-home pay is your house
payment yeah you can't do that
it's not gonna work for you this house
is not a blessing it's curse yeah you
need to sell it I'm sorry I know you and
the kids already been through a lot and
I know you're you hate moving and I know
you hate moving them away from their
buddies or whatever but you guys not
being financially stressed out is gonna
be more important for them long-term
than trying to hold on to a house it's a
part of a broken dream that turned into
a nightmare I'm sorry so how do I move
out if I can't get an apartment because
there's a book leases on that mm-hmm you
can you just have to talk to a landlord
that will help that you can teach them
what's going on I've gone through a
divorce here's my income I can afford
this that broken lease is way in the
past I've just not ever been able to get
it settled I'm gonna get it settled one
of these days and just talk them through
it and you just got a you tell MIT's
there you don't let them discover it but
you know this happened in the past it
was a long time ago and this is what's
going on but you you it doesn't matter
you've got to find another place to live
and what in the world I mean what is
your interest rate on this freakin car
well my ex-husband when he bought the
car he packed on his like $10,000 onto
the loan of the car and so because we
had four children and this was the only
car that we had that could carry out
four I took the car because I was a
stay-at-home mom and I didn't have any
money to go and finance a new car which
this is gonna make sure you have no
money a six hundred and seventy three
dollar car payment yes oh my lord honey
okay so here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna sell the house you're gonna
take some of the money from the house
you're gonna buy another car and you're
gonna sell this car or you just pay this
car off pay it off from the sale of the
house but you cannot you know when you
go in through this divorce let me tell
you what you got you got handed all the
bad eggs in the carton you got handed a
house you couldn't afford and a car
payment that is jacked up you got
screwed in this divorce settlement you
had done it to yourself because you
thought you needed all this stuff but
the net result is you ended up with two
things both of which are bad and both of
which need to be cleaned up so if you're
going to keep the car sell the house pay
off the car and get you a rental place
and we want you to go through Financial
Peace University as our guest we're
going to walk with you and help you do
everything you can to make the money
that you've got coming in stretch and
then long term you've got some career
things you're gonna have to do because
for kids on almost no alimony and no
child support at 20 grands gonna be very
tough yeah and so I want to encourage
you to reach out to get connected with
one of our real estate ELP s these are
gonna walk you through the home sale
process we'll be able to guide you and
also probably be able to guide you with
getting connected on places to rent so
go to Dave Ramsey comm slash agents
again these are people that we trust all
around the country hey where'd she go
okay I'm gonna bring you back up trying
to make that make this phone work here
how much is the settlement on the whole
bad rent lease thing thirty-two hungry
okay here's how you okay here's how you
fix it you pay off the car and you pay
those guys off when you sell your house
and then it's gone okay and you you know
you get it in writing from them that
it's paid in full and then if a landlord
ask oh you waive that piece of paper in
front of that landlord and go paid in
full
I got no car payment got no house
payment I make 20 thousand dollars a
year and I got another twenty thousand
dollars a year coming in in child
support and I can afford your rent and
you get you something with some cheap
rent that you can put everybody in even
if it's uncomfortable right now it's
more uncomfortable to be financially run
over by a bulldozer and that's where you
are right now you're getting run over
and it's temporary estimate its
temporary is the first step to healing
after the marriage ended that's right
that's exactly right I'm so sorry honey
we'll walk with you get get on real
estate alt off the website like Chris
told you to do and hang on Madison will
pick up and will give you a year
subscription to financial peace and
you through the class and get in the you
get in those clouds there's coaches in
there baby steps tracker is in there
that every dollar app is in there use
all of it and help you turn this around
and we'll walk with you as you heal this
process for your family what a mess you
know I one of the things if you're out
there and I hope you're not but during
kovat we've seen the divorce rates go up
yeah and if you're out there going
through a marriage ending event whether
I'm I'm not advocating that this is
right but I am saying that's a
statistical fact typically the lady
makes less than the gentleman not always
but the typical statistical scenario is
and you know you're going through a
divorce don't take on a payment you
can't afford in order to protect the
children's friendships or their school
district right because it's going to
stress you out and freak you out and
you've jumped from one bad situation
into another situation that's worse
that's exactly while you're at it go
ahead and get a property don't take the
house get a property you can afford yeah